the ability of just about anyone to
contact everyone anywhere in the world
is down to this man Tim berners-lee as a
young English physicist berners-lee came
up with a program language that enabled
computers connected to the Internet to
exchange data back then he was more
concerned about linking academic
computers around the world the science
community and something else Tim
berners-lee didn't get his language
patented the world wide web was free of
charge from the beginning on that might
have had something to do with how the
internet swept and changed the world in
such a short time well we're getting to
this point in just a few months when for
the first time more than half the world
will built will be online we're calling
it a 50/50 moment and that's a moment
where I think we've got to do two things
firstly we've got to say what about the
next 50% and there's a lot of challenge
in how we're going to get everybody
connected or even the most the majority
of the world connected but there's also
of course a lot to do to make the web
better and and whether that's dealing
with privacy concerns with content
online with governments censoring or
cutting access to the web in different
parts of the world there's lots to do to
make sure that we're getting the web we
want not a web that actually hurts
humanity because that's the downside
enormous ly powerful tech conglomerates
like Facebook and Google who collect
collate and monetize personal data
governments that spy on their citizens
they make berners-lee livid so nowadays
he's working to help Internet users
regain control and ownership of their
personal data GW business reporter Rob
Watts has more on this story for us hi
Rob thank you for joining us it's hard
to believe so 30 years ago the entire
world wide web was created yes that's
right and what is important to
differentiate between is the Internet
and the world wide web so the Internet
is something that's been around since
the 1960s in one form or another and
what we're talking about today is the
www dot that we know the World Wide Web
it's what we accessed when we go onto a
web browser such as Firefox or Safari or
Internet Explorer
and that was proposed thirty years ago
by a man called Tim berners-lee we can
actually see him on this picture here
third from the third from the left
celebrating at CERN where he was working
at the time 30 years ago and he proposed
what at the time he called an
information management system and it was
a way in which all the different
computers at CERN could talk to each
other and share information that until
that point have been incompatible with
each other so it's a pretty incredible
accomplishment but it sounds like Tim
berners-lee is actually not that happy
with what the World Wide Web has become
no I mean he invented it to be a great
leveler that everyone could access for
free that everyone could pool all of
their information and then all together
we could solve the world's problems but
he has in the past few days and speaking
about this and indeed today at CERN
saying that he has concerns about the
direction in which the World Wide Web
has gone to since he invented it there
are three things in particular that he
points out that upset him at state
actors using his tool to spread
misinformation he talks about
advertising models that encourage
clickbait so information that's not
really of any great informative value he
also doesn't like the way that the
Internet has encouraged outraged and
polarizing debate it certainly has you
know the World Wide Web was always free
it still is technically but we do kind
of pay a price don't we for what we do
online yeah I mean sometimes we
literally pay a price you know to access
certain websites which Tim berners-lee
might say is against his original
principle but also the big thing that we
all pay with is data and it's something
that Tim berners-lee is trying to change
in fact he's part of a group that's
trying to establish what are called pods
ways in which that people can keep all
of their data in one place and then
control how the likes of Facebook Google
Amazon accessed that data and what data
they can access
he's also pushing for something that's
he caused the contract for the web which
is an international set of laws signed
up to by the nations of the world that
can
how we all use the internet and how our
information is used maybe a way to
change the next 30 years of the World
Wide Web all right Rob Watts thank you
so much or business reporter with this
story thank you